what up guys welcome to the just par
things YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts where I give my
thoughts over morning coffee um so right
now I'm
home and when I'm home I get this like
sense of I don't know
peace and that's like the best way I can
describe it it's like a sense of peace
that I don't really get anywhere
else
um and you really you can't like buy
that and it's been kind of weird cuz
I've been filming for this
documentary and it's made me go back to
a lot of the places like I used to hang
out for it um because this documentary
is going to talk
about um sort of like my journey I guess
in the red pill how I became red
[Music]
pilled and I'm kind of at a weird
spot because when I came into the red
pill stuff
um I really was just like Curious
[Music]
um I when I first heard Kevin Samuels
I'd never heard a guy like talk like
that it was so
direct and it kind of triggered me I was
kind of upset at first not upset but I
kind of you know I mean how I angre
you're really going to be but I was more
kind of I just thought he was kind of
douchy and I kind of went through the
not all women are like that stage
the it's just the women you're around
whatever but I couldn't stop watching
and then I watched
myON I liked him
less and then I watched alpha male
strategies I watched um John Anthony
lifestyle playing with fire like I can't
even I've watched hundreds of
videos and in these
videos I realized like everything they
teach us in
school everything we see on TV about
relationships everything we've been told
about our
parents um told from our parents about
relationships is just like a lie and
maybe not a lie but it's
outdated and I'm not trying to be a
Doomer guys and a lot of times you guys
you'll say pearl
you're a Doomer you're you're just a
Doomer and what I realized is when women
are left to our own devices just off of
the all the content I've consumed the
things I've read Etc when women are left
to our own devices we want 10% of
men we will organize ourselves into
Herms and share
men and many women think that maybe
they're not like that or whatever but
most women have shared a man at some
point either in a
situationship or shared a boyfriend they
just didn't know
it and men when left to their biological
like devices they'll screw as many
chicks as
possible and they're kind of wired to
cheat where women are always wired to
kind of go on to the next best thing to
like do
better because because they had to
filter out the best
genes and before we had all this stuff
in place to stop it you know there was
religion there was social shame you know
there was all of
these containers to both of our
sexualities but now with the
internet and more choice
women's sexuality is just gone crazy
like it's perfectly acceptable for a
wife to have an open Instagram and when
you think about an open
Instagram it's really just an invitation
for a higher status man to you know
swoop in
there
and where men if they have multiple wies
or you know they want to do the Tate
thing they have a bunch of baby mamas
they're kind of shamed for it where
women if you indicate like I was even
thinking of that Isabella chick the The
Cake
Lady um for those of you that don't know
there's a girl on Twitter she's baking a
cake on Twitter right and this girl's
got big boobs okay very good-look chick
but the whole shot it's very clearly
like a thirst trap in a
way and
anyone that points out that any man that
looks at that the first thing they're
going to notice is her tits that is the
first thing you know then they'll blame
the men or whatever
but every the men are all shamed or
everybody's shamed for saying
that and so I I just I kind of got to
the point where I realized
that
monogamy is dead and it doesn't exist
anymore it is an extreme exception you
you might think I'm
crazy monogamy used to be one person for
a lifetime that's like true
monogamy it's not date one person at a
time you know now it's normal like
stepdads are kind of normal that's not
abnormal and really what what's like the
difference between between that and like
what what's the real difference between
having two wives at two different
periods in time and two wives at the
same time like why why is one better
than the
other or a situationship
or and I just kind of realized
that there's no evidence that women when
given Freedom will be less
sexual so I sort of question are are men
really the most sexual ones because
women take off their clothes so easy
like there's no tomorrow it's like the
first thing we
do and you know you find out like 4% of
people are virgins on their wedding days
and you realize the Adam 22 stuff is
going to be like so much more common in
the
future you know and I started to think
to myself what happens if we run out of
money and they take away these
government
benefits it's mostly women on these
benefits so what's going to
happen
prostitution and we're starting to see
that you have the Adam 22 stuff you have
the destiny stuff like it's
all that's the direction it's going now
I really do like like going to the
suburbs
because the city almost like warps the
way you see things and there's this girl
that always does hit pieces on me and
she's always like attacking the way I
look
whatever and I don't generally watch it
but you know sometimes I think someone
sent me something she said I don't
remember but and this girl was so
obsessed with
looks and I I kind of looked at her
Instagram and and I thought where I'm
from you would kind of look like a clown
because the way that people dress in the
cities is like different than the
suburbs and all the woke stuff is more
in the cities than the suburbs like most
people I know around here are married
maybe somewhere on a second marriage but
most people are
married and if they divorce they
remarry but I thought to myself you know
divorce was
pretty un common a 100 years ago it's
pretty common
now and then I kind of thought to myself
I thought
well single motherhood was pretty
uncommon when I was growing
up I seriously can't think of
any there was maybe like a divorce day
that came in when I was like in I
remember the first girl whose parents
got divorced was like when I was in
fourth grade or third
grade maybe a couple more later
but it's going to get more common
there's going to be more thruffle
relationships both
ways and in the suburbs it's kind of I
think it's going to go that way too
eventually
because right now we're kind of going
back to our evolutionary Roots like
everyone's getting the most Freedom that
can get so the women are going to go for
the top
men
and the
men are going to
go they're going to either be sexist or
maybe share a woman you know like a
lower value women and I'm pretty
optimistic about my future I know you
guys
aren't um I think I'll be all right but
you're still like raising your kids in
that
world and there's not really much you
can do about it and I think there's like
um a phase maybe people go through in
their early 20s and there's something
like inspiring about this phase where
you kind of feel like you can conquer
the world you're so
energetic
um
and
you get to your later 20s your 30s and
you start to realize think things are
are kind of going to stay this way for
the time being this is the direction the
world's going
in and for what every like billion
people that thinks they can change
things there's
always there's maybe you know one that
does and I think that's why the death of
Kevin Samuels like saddens me because
that man was starting a movement he was
really getting people together he was
actually like people were getting
married
and I don't
know that that sort of movement and like
Mass Appeal doesn't happen overly often
so I don't know I guess I guess this is
my morning it's a night anyway but my
thought is
that
the world is going this
way and I don't really know what to do
about it because I do believe
that
traditionalism is the best way
forward and I do believe that's why
we're so confused because they tell us
to be
egalitarian and that's why our
relationships partially don't
work um but
I also think you can't really go
back and so there has to be Evolutions
going
forward and I have to think more about
what the evolutions are
but I don't
know let me know what you guys think in
the comments um you know these these
coffee thoughts are just my tangent so
if I'm scatterbrained and
disorganized this is what these are let
me know what you think in the comments
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel I'll talk to you next
time